you hosted the webby awards okay and and
I guess you hurt the founder of Tinder's
feelings yeah you that got the founder
of tinder upset what did you say I said
what tender was what people like to use
it to have location-based sex yeah and
they're like no it's more than that
people I'm sure people have gotten
married or had long-term relationships
from tinder but a lot of people have
just had some strange I think see them
if they should embrace that yeah it that
they like all this just bigger than that
people use your app to bone strangers
embrace that be self-aware about it and
just be a happy billionaire yeah and so
they were upset that you made some joke
about it and they were upset that you
they thought no that's not what it's
about we're we're about relationship
building and they that was them cut
because of the problem I guess
oh man but you know just keep people
keep boning that's right is that your
message to America that is my one was
one of my messages to America keep Bonin
and the other one is if you have
triplets give one away
yeah the man with a message yeah you
gotta you gotta have principles you
gotta have passion if you passionate
about something it's easy to get people
passionate that's good that's good
you're good for this country wasn't that
a great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]